so I don't know about you but I'm most
familiar of looking at at Dan Gilmore's
byline photo which I did for for a
couple of decades he for the better part
of two decades was writing for the San
Jose Mercury News for Silicon Valley com
that's amongst dozens of other
publications he's written for it before
and since his most recent book is media
active which talks about how all of us
can become better consumers of media
better and smarter consumers of media
and that continues to be a mission that
he's on in his more recent work he's
currently at the Arizona State
University Walter Cronkite School of
Journalism and communication and we're
gonna hear more about what he's doing
and and what he sees the future of of
journalism and of us as media consumers
that's of a big round of applause for
Dan
[Applause]
thank you so much for coming out tonight
this Auto robots pretty cool I gather
they used to do the drawing while people
were speaking of course at that point no
one glanced at the speaker or let heard
a word of what they were saying so I
think this is a better approach forgive
me I'm a little bit hoarse I'm coming
off a cold and and then breathing the
fine air and the bay area which has been
a Challenger so you'll forgive that I
hope I I'm gonna try to talk about a few
things that are I think relevant to
where we are today with media somewhere
a bit about where we're going I I'm not
nearly smart enough to tell you what is
going to happen in media and journalism
every time I think I know something like
that
I get surprised so let's be surprised
together in the future years and
hopefully in a good way I'm I wish I
were confident that that's going to be
the case since we're at the long now
foundation I thought I would do a long
look backward first at where we've been
with media how it got to where it is and
[Music]
on the principle that knowing where
we're going it helps if you know where
you are and how you got there so I'm
gonna give you the briefest history of
media that were here
going way back I am thinking that media
in the form of something someone created
and that told a story and left it for
someone else that that may have started
with the cave drawings in this case in
France millennia ago I think of it as a
sort of an you know early beta is 0.1
had I lived here so long that I put
version numbers on everything so forgive
me I'm in career 7.3 maybe the scrolls
papyrus the first instance of something
like paper would be the next a next area
of media and we're getting close to
shipping version of media with a thing
that you recognize it's a book and thing
about these books is that they were
written by hand they were Bibles written
by people who literally did them one at
a time
and here's another Bible but something
happened you know to profoundly change
but their present and ours and that's of
course the Gutenberg Bible the printing
press the meaning of the idea that we
could do a one-to-many kind of thing and
we could print stuff whose still
reverberating in our lives today
perhaps the using of media for political
purposes and social would be a dot one
kind of advance and then moving swiftly
ahead we come to the Telegraph which had
a pretty amazing change before the
Telegraph the fastest that information
could travel was as fast as a train
could go or a horse could run that was
as fast as what suddenly it was going at
something close to the speed of light
and if you have the time I recommend a
book by Tom Standage called the
Victorian Internet where he looks at the
telegraph and shows what profound
changes it caused throughout society and
societies and it changed everything from
economics to warfare to all sorts of
things and it also led to journalism
becoming more modern
because correspondents were suddenly in
the field reporting back to people from
in almost instantly I think the late
19th early 20th century is the height of
print in the sense that it was the most
important medium of the time by far and
had such impact on society not as
powerful it's more recent ones but very
very powerful then the next big
breakthrough I think it deserves its own
version number is the radio broadcast
suddenly one-to-many at the speed of
light this was new and used for
wonderful purposes for bad purposes but
another transformative thing in how we
had media TV comes along I won't spend
too much time on it but the I think the
moon-landing watched by a couple of
billion people around the planet
simultaneously was another one of those
staggering change moments in how we got
our information the whole world pulling
together
anyone who studied communications knows
that top diagram it's by Claude Shannon
who invented information theory and very
clear and accurate portrayal of how
information flowed in the 20th century
for sure things have changed in that but
the 20th century media late 20th century
especially was a manufacturer
model where we make stuff and then put
it in trucks and send it out
distribution manufacturing distribution
if it was a broadcast we'd make the
program and send it out over the
airwaves
more recently cable and satellite that
was manufacturing distribution and then
this happens and Claude Shannon if he
were doing that today would have a
better diagram than this but it would
still be confusing because we aren't
sure we're getting better at it and one
of the really big differences that I
think people in journalism the business
I was in for so long don't still quite
get at least older ones is that it's not
the manufacturer distribute model as it
was now we make stuff we still make
stuff but we put it somewhere online and
other people come and get it that's
really different than distribution in
the old style and the distribution piece
of it is letting people know it's there
essentially or having them find it
that's that's quite different than what
I was used to so many things have
happened because of it that I think are
great and scary and all sorts of
adjectives but the thing I've spent a
lot of my work on the last 20 years is
the notion that the consumer is no
longer just a consumer but became a
creator because the democratized tools
were available to everyone and more so
all the time but these are inherently
collaborative tools so the creators are
becoming collaborators for all of the
great stuff that can happen in all of
the terrible stuff that can happen but
that's a profound change and that's our
future in part and so are things like
this I could do a hundred things this
but this is thing called safecast
it's a combination of human intelligence
machine intelligence
sensor data measuring environmental
things all put together by people
working together on a project that is
for me quite interesting and about the
future of media because it combines a
lot and it's only going to get more so
this is in Northeast country of Island
in Japan where they're measuring
radiation levels in the region near
Fukushima nuclear plants and it's a
project done by people in the
communities not by government in fact
they did it because they didn't trust
the government and something important
there about trust and how we can do a
lot of these things ourselves
so as journalism has evolved and I've
spent a lot of time in that early part
of the Internet age thinking about it
and doing it you know one thing we know
is that the supply now is greater than
ever vast supply we've a few things that
we need are going missing which is scary
like local news that we can have some
reason to believe but we're working on
that and there are things that tell me
that we may get this right eventually
vast vast supply but the lines are
blurred from what they used to be so
I'll give you a couple of edge cases
that we can agree on that that's
journalism now it's not that the post
always is right they screw up a lot but
they're basically doing journalism and I
think we could agree on that there might
be people in Washington on Pennsylvania
Avenue who would challenge that but I'm
gonna stick with that that that's
journalism that's not and you know no
comment on the on the content here just
it's not journalism whereas again best
broadcast news in the world is the BBC I
think we certainly English language and
clearly journalism even though they're
not perfect that they are fabulously
good and this is not I want to be really
clear I love the fact that people create
media and I love the fact that NAT and
foxy some friend of NAT and Foxy's did a
video of their bad dancing and put it up
on YouTube and that 50 people or so
watched it I think that's wonderful
absolutely wonderful it's just not
journalism that's my only point it gets
blurrier in every way when we starts
thinking about what's happened in the
last 20 years with people walking around
with the tools of media creation in
their pockets this young woman named
Nita was shot and killed in the streets
of Tehran a decade ago or maybe a little
more probably by a government sniper and
someone walking by with a video camera
that was inside of his telephone took
heartbreaking video of her death in the
street and this made its way around the
world in fact it later won a very major
journalism award the video but it was
taken by someone who has never was never
a journalist before and hasn't been in
one since it was a random act of
journalism which we all can do and
increasingly we should think about what
what we will do and were in that
position when we can something happened
when they the bridge in Minneapolis fell
the interstate bridge something
fascinating happened normally people
when there's some you know loud
explosion and things crashing they run
away people were running toward it with
their phones to take pictures that's
interesting and we have the ability to
witness now in ways that have been
changing and of course the most
photographed event probably in history
the tsunami that hit
Japan after the 2011 earthquake which in
turn led to the meltdown at Fukushima
again people who are not journalists
doing acts of journalism part of what's
going on in journalism is that there's a
low barrier to entry economically you
don't need a lot of money to start
something it can help if you have a lot
of money but it doesn't absolutely it's
not absolutely necessary for certain
things so someone like Josh Marshall
starts a blog a solo blog and I think
about 2000 and has now turned it into a
real real journalism business with
investors and profits and a terrific
staff doing specific kind of work that
is a must read if you follow politics
but it can be close to home it can be
for-profit at and who knows if there's
any profits at all with Berkeley side
but it's doing something that local
media are not which is getting local and
we need more and more of these and
there's a lot happening but it's the
not-for-profit in the in Singapore
that's challenging the government
censors and being media that they didn't
have before and I want to add a category
in the journalism ecosystem I believe
that the kinds of entities that are
advocates but honest advocates are
filling in a journalistic role that we
should recognize and be really happy
about whether we agree with what they're
advocating for or not so who does the
best coverage of human rights in the
world it's not the New York Times or the
BBC or anybody else it's Human Rights
Watch period now they're advocates they
have a position but they're honest and
they are very transparent about what
they're doing what's the best journalism
going on today
about civil liberties well there's some
good stuff coming out of the Washington
Post and The New York Times and I also
else were but I think the American Civil
Liberties Union does the best journalism
on the topic of civil liberties again
with a with a very clear point of view
and deep detailed research and writing
and reports that's what's new and it
belongs in the ecosystem so I'm in the
when it comes to journals I'm in the and
camp it's not one or the other it's a we
it's additive and we're finding
incredibly wonderful and useful and
important content that we never had
before if we think of it as part of an
ecosystem and I this is a really bad
stab at an ecosystem chart but some of
this in the context of what we're
grappling with today which we'll talk
about a bit I think is close i I welcome
Corrections so even though some really
important things are going missing in
journalism and we could be in for some
news deserts around the country when it
comes to local and that's very bad
but people again are working on it
there's an enormous supply I've been in
the last few years worried about the
demand more than anything else
partly because people have been content
to get their information in that fashion
and that there's so much of it and so
much is garbage or worse as we've
discovered in the last well we haven't
just discovered it but it's become a
national emergency or an international
in the last year the notion of accuracy
and trust are problematic in a world of
Photoshop and tools like it where images
like that which is a composite race
around the world after
vents and someone is made up whole cloth
to pretend some things are happening and
yes it was debunked and yes it went that
went around too but probably there are
still people who saw that but who think
it's real we have ways of helping truth
catch up with lies but that's not enough
for all kinds of reasons if you want to
ask about that later glad to do it it's
not just people with Photoshop in their
classroom or basement or somewhere else
it's people at our best organizations
who profoundly screw up and in some
cases helps get Wars going so we have a
lot of work to do in traditional media
we need to improve the supply in every
way but I still trust more than not I've
been thinking about what to call some of
this and I that title there I've given
it as the disinformation political
technical industrial complex and it's a
little bit too long for a tweet but it
it feels like this is something we're
having to deal with now and the the
taxonomy here that Dana Boyd and her
folks that data in society did on
misinformation disinformation etc is
wonderful to look at and give you a lot
of guides the things that we're dealing
with are really troubling by the way I
don't like the expression fake news I
think we're stuck with it but I don't
like it for for really two reasons one
is I just I hate the idea that you put
fake next to news that just feels wrong
and the other is that people who lie all
the time have taken it over and are
using it against people who don't lie
all the time
so I would prefer that we use words from
the taxonomy and and things like that
but it's really problematic and it's
worse when we're dealing with it in a
context of companies that
do brilliantly what they do but that
what they do is used by bad actors in
ways that the good actors are only just
figuring out and trying to catch up with
we have a huge problem here if you want
to talk about this later on I want to
just say one thing about all of the
calls I'm hearing for the platform
companies to to become you know titute
to root out bad stuff that sounds really
good I worry about us getting what we
want if that's what we really want and
you can ask me about why later on but
let's be careful about getting what we
want in this case you need to point out
this is not new if you walk by a
supermarket checkout span any time in
the last 50 years you've seen lots of
misinformation sells brilliantly it's
incredibly profitable to sell lies not
just for ideology but for money and
about not quite a year ago the CEO of
CBS made that comment which if we don't
do something may well be the epitaph of
journalism we have to get the people who
were in charge to care more about what
they visibly don't and they even worse
news is that this is going to get a lot
worse techniques are now coming along to
make it possible to create videos that
show people doing things they didn't do
and saying things that they didn't say
there's a great demonstration of this at
the University of Washington putting
words in Obama's mouth and it's very
persuasive and it's just starting in how
in the quality and
in this situation but the the people who
want to fake us out are going to be just
reveling in the tools they have to do it
with which makes me wonder if we are
going to need something like Robert
Heinlein wrote about in one of his
science fiction books which was the
notion of a human being as a quote fair
witness that that would be the answer in
the long run I you know they may be a
journalist but the fair witnesses that
he was talking about are a very
different thing that's again off topic
but with that there are technological
possibilities we don't have time to get
into but using blockchain and other
things maybe of authenticating things
like photos and videos and other media
that might not have been possible in the
past I'm again I'm not smart enough to
figure out how to fix the business model
I'm working in the area that people have
called news literacy and some adjacent
parts that related to media literacy but
basically critical thinking is the the
heart of it and I'll tell you more about
that but I and some principles that are
basic to both consuming and creating
media and we're all doing both all the
time I don't like the word consumer but
I'm stuck with it like I think I'm
probably stuck with fake news and so the
principles I work on teach when I teach
my course for people who are reading or
watching listening etcetera is being you
know just skeptical of absolutely
everything but not equally skeptical of
everything use judgment and and I have
in the back of my mind all when I look
at media
various kinds and journalism a kind of
credibility scale it just it's just back
there or somewhere and so you can see
that at the BBC which I obviously
respect a lot is more over there on the
positive side and not universally but
there and you know BuzzFeed's all over
the place YouTube all over the place but
moving more to the negative in terms of
information quality and anonymous
comments way over on the left the thing
I want you to notice about this is that
it doesn't start at zero that anonymous
commenter would have would have to work
incredibly hard just to have no
credibility at all something sucked
credibility out of the atmosphere it's
like you know this monster thing going
on and a lot of what we're seeing now is
yanking credibility from our ecosystem
but I hope you have something like that
in mind that you don't start with zero
you can start way way in a deficit and
that it takes something to earn it you
have to do something to earn even no
credibility and that we have to ask
questions when we're doing any kind of
reading where it's going to be something
we care about whether it's to read
something else on the same topic or as
that's an email from a local official in
my town where we live in Brisbane
answering a question I had about a
situation with the water in town they
okay I found out going outside of our
comfort zones crucial both politically
and culturally we don't do that enough
we don't look for things that are
outside of what we believe and we don't
get much help on this from Facebook we
need more help from them in going
outside our comfort zones and we have to
be relentless with our own biases
there's a thing called confirmation bias
where we tend to believe things and if
someone points out that were wrong with
facts we tend to believe it even more
that's really terrifying that that's
true but we there are ways to work on
impart us to recognize our biases so we
need to spend more time on these and
then finally we need to learn these
techniques of media how meteor created
and by the way every teenager is very
good at that and also though how meteor
used to persuade and manipulate none of
us is good enough at that and remember
we're in a world where we're creating
all the time even if it's only through
the act of sharing that's an act of
media creation that goes on a gazillion
times per second and it's shaping what
we know as societies around the world
and we better recognize that we're
creating in ways that we've never
thought about and that gets to this
notion of this principles for people who
are creating I'm not talking about
creating a bad video on for YouTube but
I'm talking about if you want people to
trust you you have the certain
principles to follow and the first four
of those would be kind of journalism 101
we don't do it on everything we do but
they're they're useful principles the
one I'm adding for the 21st century is
transparency which is something
journalists don't do typically and I'm
working on a project to help them do
more of it but I try to follow
transparency principles in what I do and
when I screwed up on Twitter a while
back I put a long thread about how I had
screwed up what what happened and the
basic thing was I believed something bad
about some people I don't like that's
dangerous in fact you should be the more
you want to believe something that you
see that's flying by and your social
feed the more skeptical you should be
about it and especially skeptical if
it's confirming something
if it's saying something bad about
someone you don't like in this case it
was the Daily Mail which I consider the
toxic waste dump of all journalism but I
believe something about them that turned
out not to be true and I had to
apologize to people because I was I got
it wrong
brian Stelter at CNN is doing wonderful
work in this trying to help his audience
understand what's at stake here and to
be more careful in what they do I also
want for us to work on what I'm thinking
of as slow news it's related to slow
food where we just take a breath take
our time
I wish journalists would do that but
they're not going to I can tell you from
experience that's not going to happen
there there are some efforts to you know
hold things and so they're right but
it's we don't live in that world anymore
and we never really did the getting a
scoop and deadlines and all sorts of
things conspire against journalistic
slow news but we as the people who are
the providing the demand for things
could do better at it and it takes all
sorts of methods a scientist friend of
mine told me that when whenever he sees
a report whether it's in print or
broadcast or whatever about some
breakthrough in science or medicine he
puts it immediately and automatically
into the following category I think that
interesting is true is probably the
default category we should use for
everything it would I think we'd get a
lot better results a lot of my work
lately has been can we make these into
these principles and these ideas can we
make them scale I think it's a good idea
to do that and I so I'm working to try
and make them scale who can do it well
teachers we did a MOOC
open online course but you know
realistically the people who are
teaching this stuff not very many
critical thinking is not required in
lots of classrooms around the country
California rejected a bill to make media
literacy part of the curriculum in this
session they didn't exactly reject it
they just never quite got around to
voting on it so maybe that's the same
thing so that's not going to scale and
then you know let's face it in parts of
this country teaching critical thinking
would get the teacher fired as a
dangerous radical so that's that we can
make it scale somewhere and some places
that way who else well what about the
news media which completely failed to
make this part of their mission part of
what I'm working on now is to help them
make it part of their mission they still
have scale and they can still do a lot
but let's get to where scale is if we
want to in this society it's the
platforms and they're starting to wake
up and starting to think about doing
this they're making small steps I wish
they do more but I want to see them help
us be better at our demand side of the
media supply and demand equation and I
think we're making some progress in the
last two weeks Facebook and several
other funders have helped my university
I I still live here in Bay Area go there
once a month for a few days and we're
gonna do a we started something we're
calling the news collab at so as it
sounds a collaborative lab to do
experiments working with people who want
to make this kind of literacy and and
news awareness scale to higher levels
you working with anybody who wants to
play and right now our first project is
going to be with the McClatchy newspaper
and web company in three of their cities
to see if they can
work better with the community to do
this and we have other projects in the
works but I think yeah you know I'm not
gonna solve any of this but we can make
it dent I hope that's that's a good goal
the other thing about where we are and
this is quite related to the earlier
stuff is the issue of control and it's
pretty crucial because we're seeing
something going on that has been going
on really pretty much since the internet
got going despite the wonderful radical
decentralization of Technology and
communications every time things like
this happen people want to get control
of it and resent relized stuff and the
problem is that a lot of the decisions
now that are being made about speech
about innovation about assembly about
things we care about you know society
based on Liberty are being taken away
from us
sometimes we're handing them over as
part of our daily use of Technology we
should recognize that but there's a very
strong recent realization into control
and chokepoints that are quite dangerous
to think about and to see what's
happening and it really comes down to
who's going to decide on net neutrality
who's going to decide what bits of
information get to your device in what
odor for in what order at what speed and
whether they get there at all and I
think it ought to be you who decides
that us but the telecoms think that it
should be then and right now they're
winning and it's going to get ugly if
they do regain this kind of control and
then asserted in ways that I think are
likely it won't be I don't think they'll
be that clumsy about it but give them
time who decides whether remember the
distribution is now being
found having people know where your
stuff as well our friends at Google make
very important tweaks to their search
algorithm all the time usually because
they want to stifle spammers sometimes
for less noble reasons but things that
are good get lost as a result that's a
lot of power in the cans of a single
company awful lot of power talked about
your news feed well you know it's not
yours it's it's the thing you see but
Facebook makes a lot of decisions and I
think we have to really be demanding
more of companies that have this kind of
control I'd like to see more antitrust
enforcement there's a lot of things I'd
like to see but we're we're not fully
confronting what's going on another
control area is how do you get paid
whatever you think of WikiLeaks you
should not be happy that a few years ago
the major payment systems shut them down
for donations just shut it down probably
at the request of the United States
government if you can't get paid for
your work it's gonna be kind of hard to
have dinner and have a place to live and
if they can do it to WikiLeaks they can
do it to anybody that got very little
attention that should have gotten more
governments are constantly helping
corporate control freaks and the DMCA
Digital Millennium Copyright Act is one
of the clearest examples of that but
outright censorship is growing around
the world and in places including
democracies and it's getting dangerous
again to be a journalist in much of the
world it's never been not dangerous in
many places but the danger is growing
just yesterday the
when who was primary reporter on the
Panama papers was murdered probably
because she had pissed off people in her
society we are in a really perilous time
because even in countries where free
presses and shrined our leaders are
waging war against it or at least a war
of words which who knows where that's
going to go and then there's the among a
number of other things the issue of
surveillance which is directly related
to journalism not just because
journalists will have trouble getting
sources and keeping sources out of jail
or themselves under a pervasive
surveillance regime but surveillance is
really a deadening thing to societies in
all kinds of ways not just journalists
this is a this deadens it chills speech
it will chill almost everything and we
should all be thinking about how we can
I think how we can not have pervasive
surveillance though our governments
plural and corporations plural are doing
their damnedest to make sure we don't
get a choice maybe we should be working
harder ourselves to do things this by
the way that is part of the book I'm
working on has to do with what we can do
to regain some control what I don't want
to see is a world where we need
permission and that's what centralized
control requires is permission from
other people I don't want permission in
particular in the context of tonight to
publish or to speak that's that's wrong
that's bad we have to prevent that and I
just want to say again that this
incredible technology revolution
which I still believe is more good than
bad by a long margin is not something
that should be controlled at the center
or by governments but by us that's hard
to do though easy to say and I'm gonna
stop there and take questions from all
of you because I'm much more interested
in knowing what you want to hear about
and but thank you for coming that's how
[Applause]
thank you Dan and we are gonna take
questions and Dan is also gonna stick
around afterwards as we always do here
so definitely stick around and I feeling
we won't get to everybody's question but
you'll be around and available so we can
keep this conversation going
Rio has the microphone she's in the back
if you get her attention she'll she'll
get you the mic also to the folks on the
livestream thanks so much for for being
there and if you put things in chat then
we will we will get them asked let me
ask you Dan start off you touched on it
just a second before about getting
informed about other viewpoints exposing
ourselves to other things really
dampening down the polarization if I can
put that word is that is that what you
would say and if you say another word
about maybe because it seems like that
is that in some ways readies things for
these more nefarious elements that are
that are putting fake information out
there for us that the polarization
enables that that enables those biases
but but what do you agree with that or
what are your thoughts on it
there's no question that some bad people
are doing their best to make us hate
each other I think that's part of the
game
and we have to we have to first of all
real you know recognize that we're being
manipulated and people are starting to
pick up on that we're starting to
understand that better but I have I have
a bunch of people I follow and read
because I know that my blood will boil
when I read it and and I try to pick the
ones who are honest and they're you know
there are a lot of folks I this may be
my bias I'm speaking but I think I see a
lot more dishonesty on the right than on
the left right now but I probably could
be I could be persuaded that that's
wrong though I think it would be
difficult but I think it's important to
at the very least know what people I
disagree with are saying I have to do
that if I want to be able to carry on an
intelligent conversation and it's you
know the other thing is I learned stuff
from people who think I'm I learned more
from people who think I'm wrong than
people think I'm right this is a I think
should be true of everybody so does that
solve polarization no but it helps me a
little bit be a better person I think
and better and understand the world
better and we've got a question in the
back make sure you hold the mic up close
as you're talking and do it hi there hi
can you comment on the relationship
between the values that you you
mentioned of transparency and non
anonymity for journalists but then also
the political privilege that that is to
present news in a way where or you can
talk about who you are if I fully
understand
for the longest time like it wasn't that
long and in a room where the long now is
for a really brief time in history
incredibly brief now that I think
journalists pretended to something
called objectivity which is a really
nice word kind of like a unicorn doesn't
exist in the real world but it's I don't
know if any we aspire to having unicorns
but we do aspire to something like
objectivity in the journalism craft and
that's not a that's not altogether wrong
I mean I want journalism by people who
will look for as many facts and angles
and and things about the topic they're
writing about as possible and and
present me with lots of nuance but even
if they do that they come from their own
background they bring bias to this and
at some level and the people like who
they talk to is a form of selection who
they don't talk et cetera so I just
prefer transparency in various forms
when it comes to journalism to the the
notion of objectivity which I just don't
think is real I prefer people saying
well here's here's my something about me
my background I think journalist could
do more of that I think they could say
if if they have a bias about something
just say it and say I'm working really
hard to overcome that to present you
with as much as possible but I love
advocacy journalism to where people go
specifically onto one side
and not that there are two sides to
everything in fact they're rarely are
two sides there are many either you know
there's many sides but I think
transparency would have the benefit of
in lots of ways and I'll give you one
specific example journalists have never
been terribly keen about telling their
audiences about the mistakes they make
and when they do it's it's usually if
it's a newspaper it's on page two days
or weeks after the error appeared and no
really no real context as to what what
happened we could do a lot better than
that and by the way and if it's on a TV
program you almost never hear a correct
so it's something and one of the
experiments I'm working on is a way to
do corrections that amplifies what you
got wrong it's an element of
transparency to I we're going to do a
tool that says to somebody who's read or
watched a if you if you if you want and
we will tell you when we've made a
correction to something that you looked
at on our or in our place and we'll
present it to you in context and we'll
do it if with email if you still use or
we'll do it on Facebook or wherever it
is you want to be told this could have
been done 15 20 years ago no one ever
did it so we're going to try and see if
it works but there's all kinds of
transparency including I think a very
fundamental one which is tell people why
how you do what you do the why is really
important but the how can be pretty good
too and no not no not everyone fact most
people don't want to read a you know the
biography of a story they want to but
there are ways to do it that if
especially if you're going into
some very deeper things the so BuzzFeed
broke the story about the former
Secretary of Health and Human Services
you know running around the world on
private planes and after they did the
story and they were is pretty great they
they did a piece about how they how they
reported this which was fascinating they
had people stationed at little airport
fixed operator stations to look for tail
numbers of these private planes and they
this was detective work it was really
fascinating and I think that proves to
anyone who had read it that they did
relentless and good journalism so that's
what there are many ways to do
transparency those are a couple I wish
we do more we don't do anything we don't
do enough all right we've got another
question there thanks for the talk to
made one I want to add two questions one
is to take you up on your offer to ask
about be careful what if we get what we
want out of these internet platforms so
I'd love to hear more about that and
then number two is building on the
transparency piece is you know media is
increasingly not just a place of getting
information but a place of coordination
right and collaboration as you say and
it seems like I would love to hear you
talk a little bit more about what where
the trends are going around
collaboration and around building
standards of trust
seems the times and the post are
increasing their subscribership because
people feel like there's some amount of
trust there but that's still tradition
traditional platform I'm wondering if
you're seeing other sites around
collaboration there's all kinds of
interesting work going on
including news organizations working
with each other that's long overdue it's
happening now more and more but these
tools you know people it took
journalists a long time to realize that
especially in major breaking news
situations one of their major
competition one of the serious
competitors was Wikipedia which people
would turn to because if these stories
would build themselves on breaking news
now you've had you had to be careful but
something was going on that they hadn't
understood and and we're still not clear
I mean Wikipedia is this amazing
phenomenon that I don't feel it yet but
collaboration is expanding and and I
think is is going to be a pretty
standard practice over time and I'm more
excited about it when it's collaboration
with the people in your community than
when it's with another news organization
I think that's fabulous and community
can be Geographic or of interest your
first question I am cautious about we
have no precedent for the size and reach
and power of at least two companies
Facebook and Google which have an
incredible say over how we understand
the world and Facebook in particular
with conversation they kind of the
center of conversation I'm very cautious
about the idea of asking them to be the
internet police you know we don't want
them to willingly let their platforms be
used by the bad actors to either commit
fraud or to
push it push us apart or to do do the
really bad stuff we're seeing but if we
demand that they be the editors of the
internet we're gonna regret that when
they become the editors of that and and
then on their points with your new
project Facebook is is part of the the
mix there right so you've said that your
this is an interesting that dilemma for
me it's not dilemma we I'm comfortable
with it though I'm there I have friends
who are not happy with what I've done
there is I'm there is one area where I
agree with Facebook and that is on the
need to make news literacy and and
things like it more part of our public
policy and dialogue to help the the
users of media be more power to do
things for themselves that's the one
place that Facebook and I agree and they
and they have I think it's in their
interest to make that more possible and
they are helping to fund this this lab
that we're doing on the other stuff on
the idea of Facebook becoming the
internet which is clearly one of their
goals I'm totally opposed to that I
don't want they've got more than enough
power now I want to see them you know I
think Facebook is a very great company
and in some ways a very dangerous one we
have but I I will work with people I
disagree with on everything else on
things where we agree that I think are
important enough so this is one of those
times I hope if if that makes me a
hypocrite I will I will live with it
I suppose but what I'm most curious
about is one might argue that they're
already editors of the not perhaps the
Internet
but of what you're consuming and so
given that the recommendation engine and
well and the you know as we've all seen
the hundred thousand dollars an ad by a
small potatoes compared to the organic
lifts and the reach of what they serve
you every day and the fact that they
decide already algorithmically what you
are going to see and what you are not
going to see whether that's your friends
baby pictures or an article so I guess
but I'm a little bit confused about is
as we think going forward about what we
want to see from these platforms
recognizing that there's going to be a
hearing for example in November first
what is it that you would ask them and
and what is it that that you think that
our elected officials have a
responsibility to clarify with them
things I have asked them before already
and and that other people have asked
that I agree with it I think they have
to be much more forthcoming with data
for researchers too because if we want
to know how misinformation is being
spread they have it they have the data
it's you know it's it's there they need
I believe they should be more willing
and happy to work with people who can
help solve some of this that's a big ask
that I think they need to people have to
pressure them I think they could give us
the users more tools to determine what's
in our own feeds I would like to see
them do that I don't they're they're
optimized for engagement for people
doing stuff and talking and sharing I'd
like I'd like a dashboard that would
that would help I would I would like
competition for Facebook I don't think
it's healthy when single companies
dominate everything I think that's
dangerous and you know at some point
when when there's a reawakening to
antitrust I would assume that this will
become an issue again though its
standard antitrust doctrine doesn't seem
to fit with the situation that works and
it it well I think there are
possibilities but I'm not I'm not
optimistic but I there are a lot of
things I'd like to see them do and I'm
this is not gonna when you ask companies
like that to change the product that's
difficult we have a question from the
livestream your thoughts on how to
encourage media itself to embrace
critical thinking as part of its mission
and whether you see new partnerships
with players looking at mission based or
impact investing for instance I would
add to that the Marshall project for
instance is an example and if there are
other examples like that of kind of
mission based news organizations any
thoughts on that for the Marshall
project if you don't know it is a
brilliant nonprofit that is covering
criminal justice going deeper than
pretty much anybody else with with
terrific journalists Bill Keller former
executive editor of the New York Times
is running it there it's it's a terrific
operation there's a whole bunch of
things here in the Bay Area the Center
for Investigative Reporting reveal is a
great news organization that's operated
somewhat in the shadows of others but I
think deserves more there's all kinds of
things bubbling up and some are not for
profits them were for profit and and by
the way some of the for-profit
journalism stuff that got funded like
four and three and five years ago is
going to hit a wall soon because I think
there has been a bit of a bubble in in
that too and I'll get those will tweet
out those links later I'll get get kind
of loads together with you we're gonna
have one more question from the back
I've got one more thing I want to ask
you about the technological thing err so
your career has been through this
remarkable technological evolution and
so I think for all of us to get kind of
the benefit of what you've seen
obviously you can't predict the future
and those earlier technological
revolutions are not doing you know are
not a magic thing but I wonder if you
reflect on something is you've seen
websites come out blogging and then
social media become requisite for for
journalists I imagine they weren't
expecting the way that things would
change and as these latter waves of
technology hit maybe there were other
expectations I guess what are your
thoughts on how technology and media may
be thinking they're pivoting now or
dealing through this are is is the CBS
heads opinion about it's it's all just
business no matter what happens to the
world is that is that representative or
what what what what wisdom can you share
from from seeing media through these
years it's entirely representative of
television look CNN and the other news
channels gave Trump several billion with
a B dollars worth of free unedited
basically unlimited airtime in 2015-2016
and there's one well two reasons one
small one and one and one big one the
small one is that he was entertaining
and people came and watched which led to
the big one they made a ton of money
I don't see that changing you know we
are in a market-driven society and I
hope we will do better on other things
but I have no great hope that the TV
news channels are gonna do better than
they've done and there's spots where
they do good things it's not like it's
all wretched it's there are these
flashes of fine stuff here and there god
I I just don't know I do know all I can
tell you is that the and I don't know
how it's going to change journalism
exactly but - sweeping but let's assume
that the worst of the of the
centralization does not happen or is
somehow sorted and I think that then we
have something to worry about it again
which is I mean AI I don't I both have
enthralled by and and worried about is
it's the big imponderable for for
journalism and pretty much everything we
do and simultaneously something that I
and it's related is this crazily named
Internet of Things which if you look
around is just sort of going gangbusters
with as far as I can tell absolutely no
interest on the part of people deploying
it about doing it safely this is this is
a mind-boggling to me that we're heading
that way but when you add sensor and
connectivity and brains and memory to
everything that you touch that's really
interesting and how that's going to
affect everything everything but I don't
I can't tell you what the impact on
journalism will be unless it's to have a
complete panopticon who wouldn't you
know in theory would be sort of
everybody sees everybody at the same
time we've got a question from the back
end you say that there's more that's
good in technology right now than the
bad or evil and I'm very curious about
this Jane McGonigal the game theorist
has recently popularized this idea of
the urgent optimism not just in with
regards to journalism but in sort of the
state of the world we're kind a little
out early we're sort of in this place of
constant disaster or crisis fatigue but
this idea of urgent optimism I'm curious
about what you what gives you optimism
of projects or things that are happening
in journalism right now that give you
reason for hope and optimism and if you
think gamification or games are involved
in that in that hope the things that
give me hope are both both generic and
specific the engine generically the that
collaboration idea I think is still not
fully tested and the week we can there's
a lot more to come that it is pretty
exciting to me but specifically I I
could rattle off a hundred projects that
are intriguing to me that I think
present at many parts of the
for you tech folks the journalism stack
whatever that means there's a in all
places
I see heartening things albeit some very
alarming losses in places we need but we
mentioned a couple there ProPublica is
doing spectacularly good journalism and
they're doing in a way that was unheard
of twenty years ago not just because
it's online but it's started out as a
collaborative thing they're doing things
with their their I don't like the word
particularly audience but the people who
want to know what they find out there
working with them in ways that are not
typical including some crowdsourcing
getting people in the community that
they serve to help them do things
there's a related to that there's a in
the Netherlands adi correspondent is a
completely reader supported journalism
site no ads they take positions they are
totally transparent and they
specifically and deeply involve their
audience in what they're doing they're
about to launch next year a site in the
US I recommend highly that you watch for
that because I know those guys and
they're really they're really good
they're they they have they have the
right ideas and they're and they're
there put it they have an incredibly
diverse and in every way team of people
working on it who are helping to do
something I think I'll make a difference
there's I didn't even touch really on
the too much and every on people doing
using data to help us understand the
world better and perhaps make necessary
changes data is always the two-edged
sword but it's without it journalism
would be an even worse shape and on and
on I mean I spend work right now this
new lab we're doing we're we're gonna
have a we're about to hire somebody to
do a global survey of transparency and
engagement news room related
transparency and community engagement
and and we'll publish it as we go it's a
every time I turn around I find a better
example than I had the day before so the
the ferment in this sphere is pretty
amazing and I I stay weirdly optimistic
at a time when it would be really it
would be quite easy to want to give up
because there's so much that is wrong um
and to end on some thing also maybe
hopefully hopeful you mentioned your
your teaching at ASU as well as that
speaking in the writing in this this
projects tell us something you're seeing
or tell us something in the dialogue
that you have with the students that
you're talking to there that's that's
hopeful or that you see is maybe part of
the as a future my teaching is only
online at this point that's how I that's
how I can live here yeah and I'll be
Kyle be doing less of it as I work on
the project but I something that's been
making me feel a little better is that
when I talk to students in person when
I'm in Phoenix they're a lot better at
being skeptical than they used to be
they're not quite good enough of being
skeptical of their friends as they
should be
they're they're skeptical and everything
but they're friends they need to work on
but there's a there's and there's this
especially given the economic trends in
traditional journals and they're still
or there's there's this amazing desire
to do something
journalistic in the world and it doesn't
doesn't always mean they're getting
pretty savvy they know that a journalism
degree is actually good for a number of
career paths one of which is journalism
I'm I'm delighted when I hear about a
student who goes and works for a
advocacy organization or some other
group that wants to deploy those talents
I think younger people are quite
properly furious with our generation and
God help us if they don't fix it because
they're gonna have to we've made a mess
of so much of it I'm not sure if we
ended up with a hopeful thing there at
the very they are but it's good gonna
fix it they're gonna fix it all right
let's have a big round of applause and
and Dan is a small token of our thanks
this is a long now challenge coin I want
to thank you for for being here Dan's
gonna stick around please stick around
ask more questions I know there are a
lot more questions in this room let's
keep that conversation going thanks
again for coming out and making this
great night one more time for Dan thank
you everyone
[Applause]
[Music]